MARTHA MacCALLUM.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT," THE NEWS GETS WEIRDER.
ONE CERTAINTY IN THE NEWS
BUSINESS, ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION CLAIMED ANOTHER
VICTIM TODAY, SOMEONE YOU HAVE
NOT HEARD OF.
HE HAS DUTCH ATTORNEY ALEX VAN
DER ZWAAN.
HE WORKED FOR THE LAW FORM, ONE
OF THE BIGGEST FIRMS IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND INCLUDED WORK FOR UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT VICTOR JANNE KOVIC,
WORK THAT WAS ARRANGED BY
LOBBYIST PAUL MANAFORT.
IT APPEARS THAT HE WEAPONIZED A
NUMBER OF AMERICAN LAW FIRMS ON
HALF OF HIS UKRAINIAN CLIENT.
HE IS PAYING THE PRICE FOR THAT
TONIGHT, SO WHY IS ANY OF THIS
MATTER EXACTLY?
NONE OF IT AS ANYTHING TO DO
WITH DONALD TRUMP, THE 2016
IT TURNS OUT AS SOME OF US
PREDICTED, ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION HAS TAKEN OFTEN
UNPREDICTABLE DIRECTIONS.
INDICTMENTS LIKE THE ONE TODAY
EXPOSE THE TRUTH ABOUT TO THE
FOREIGN INFLUENCE.
OTHER COUNTRIES DO SUBVERT OUR
DEMOCRACY, BUT NOT WITHOUT VAST
CONSPIRACIES, THOSE ARE FAKE AND
DELUSIONAL ACTUALLY, THE REAL
THREATS, AND IT IS REAL IS
FOREIGN LOBBYING AND INFLUENCE
BUYING.
FOREIGN INTERESTS PUSH PUSH US
TO SIGN TRADE DEALS TO PASS
SPECIFIC LAWS, TOO OFTEN THEY
SUCCEED IN THAT.
THAT IS A DIVERSION TO WHAT WE
WERE PROMISED, AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT MADE BY AMERICANS.
PAID BY FOREIGN INFLUENCES
EVERYWHERE, HIDING IN PLAIN
SIGHT, VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON IMPLICATED IN SOME
WAY THAT MAY EXPLAIN WHY
WHENEVER HE MENTIONS IT.
PAUL MANAFORT IS A REPUBLICAN, A
MODESTO GROUP THAT HELPED HIM
LOBBY WAS A DEMOCRATIC FIRM,
ONE OF THE BIGGEST.
THE HEAD OF THE TEAM WORKING ON
THE ACCOUNT WAS GREG CRAIG, ONE
THE MOST FAMOUS DEMOCRATIC
OPERATIONS.
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, BEFORE
THAT A KEY ASSISTANT TO
BILL CLINTON FOR YEARS PLAYED A
HUGE PLAYER IN DEMOCRATIC
CIRCLES.
IS DAVE CRAIG ONE OF THE NEW
TARGETS?
WE CANNOT SAY, BUT WHAT IS
OBVIOUS IS THAT THIS
INVESTIGATION IS NO LONGER ABOUT
THE 2016 ELECTION.
MUELLER IS IMPOSING ON THE REAL
SCANDAL IN WASHINGTON, THE ONE